allons enfants de la patrie le jour de
gloire est arrivé oui dans nino et tuque
et chant ça y est aujourd'hui avec les
big sur un coin de trottoir pour crier
leur révolte au monde les autres dans un
coin de jardin pour célébrer le divin
mozart
et la clémence des cieux pour donner
envie à tout le monde tout le monde de
chanter
et cette année pour la première fois la
chaleur des voix a franchi une nouvelle
frontière
tiens les hôpitaux comme celui de necker
enfants malades à paris avec le trio
esperança est coté dans sa chambre à
pleurer ce qui a été enfermé enfin il
sortait pas et voyez pas la lumière du
jour
elle elle semblait vraiment beaucoup et
la cas de la ligne de la musique elle
serait jouée elle sort un peu mieux elle
est contente ça fait du bien de temps en
temps comme musique
je voudrais c'est aujourd'hui la fête à
la musique ce soit tous les jours qu'une
entendu c'est pas possible
mais je pense que en particulier dans
les hôpitaux
je crois que les activités culturelles
les activités artistiques peuvent être
développées en attendant la semaine du 4
e woodstock 17 appelé les musiques à
montrer combien elle pouvait adoucir les
coeurs
là